The joe rogan experience.
Do you know anything what's going on in Boyle Heights?
No.
Boyle Heights.
Ucla,
right?
Yeah,
it's SLA.
And um,
apparently the hipsters are starting to open up our teasing old coffee shops and
art galleries there and they're not having it.
And uh,
the neighborhoods pushing back,
it's more than that.
There's a lot of videos.
It's like straight up racist.
It's anti white racism,
which is apparently totally acceptable.
You didn't have cameras are blaring in your face.
Uh,
we'll boil heights,
be ruined by one coffee shop.
It's not just one coffee shop.
They forced a gallery under.
Is this an older story from June's?
Yeah,
they forced a gallery out just through constant harassment and they broke the
windows of this coffee shop and,
but what I watched last night there was disturbing was these air quote activists
standing in front of this gallery.
It's a fucking art gallery.
And they're screaming,
get the fuck out.
Get the fuck out of our neighborhood.
Get the fuck out.
We don't want you here.
And the guy was like trying to talk to him like,
you know some hipster guys like you know I'm,
I identify as a feminist.
Like one of those guy identifies a feminine,
you know,
one of those guys.
And he was like,
yes,
I'm here to support.
I'm here to support the QME.
We will fuck it.
Why don't you get the fuck out?
Get the fuck out there chanting,
get the fuck out,
get the fuck,
get the fuck out.
It's a great chance a sign that says fuck white art,
white fuck white art.
The coffee shop,
they broke the windows here.
The coffee shop was even more fucked up cause one of the guys is actually a
Mexican.
He slapped her.
No,
they fucked up proper.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah.
And one of the guys who won in the coffee shop,
they were calling it,
it's,
they called it like weird coffee or something like that.
And neither the,
they,
they put a sign on it calling it white coffee and they broke the window.
But one of the guys who owns it is Latino.
I don't know if he's Mexican,
but he's definitely,
it'd be funny to open up a spot called white coffee.
Yeah.
White people come.
People just called white people problems.
Look,
a new generation of anti gentrification,
radicals are on the march in Los Angeles and around the city.
This is not every dad is not an accurate way to frame what's happening.
No,
that's crazy.
This is not anti gentrification radicals.
These are,
these are writers and the writing and these people have fire in their hands or
walking in the street and they're yelling at a bunch of racist shit and they
covered their faces up.
Look,
I get it.
I get what's going on.
Like they're,
they're afraid they're gonna lose their neighborhood and they're afraid their
neighborhood's going to be pushed out.
The dinosaurs felt the same way.
So to,
yeah,
so did cavemen.
Everybody feels the same way.
The world is a fucking fluid moving thing.
You can't just save neighborhoods forever.
It just doesn't work that way.
You can't save anything forever.
No.
I mean,
and there's nothing wrong with it.
God Damn Gallery moving into your neighborhood.
That's crazy.
Right,
right.
Like,
like I,
I see it when people do this whole thing about like Walmart's moving into small
towns and that they lose,
they panic.
Like I get that.
I understand it's changing industry.
A dude selling fucking lattes is not going to dynamically shaper and,
and if it does it'll take 15 more more years.
Yeah,
it'll take 15 more years.
But they know it's coming.
They know what happens in these neighborhoods.
It's like these hipsters move in first because La real estate is so ridiculous
and it doesn't make,
like I was looking at places near where Collin lives,
cow lives in Santa Monica and I was looking at places like he lives above
ground.
Yes,
I know right.
He lived in like the sewer system or something like that.
I can think like one of them Ninja turtle because the turtle that can live on
the beat,
the scoring system.
He lives in a very nice neighborhood.
I mean I'm not,
but I was just looking in Santa Monica in general and a regular house,
like a regular house is $2 million.
Yeah.
Bullshit House.
Like it was a fucking normal house house.
Nothing like you be like,
you can bring a a gal back home like,
hey my house.
Huh?
You know,
look at the view of the city.
No,
there's none of that Arrow or $2 million.
You get a shack two bed.
One and a half bath.
Yeah.
With the fucking old bullshit linoleum.
Shitty sync with the ring.
Where at the fucking water.
The dirt has just stayed in those old la La loves doing like,
uh,
in the 60s they love doing like a or in the 50s,
maybe pink like pink and green bathrooms.
So it was like pink tile.
Yeah.
And they leave that and ultra,
um,
I was just looking today Deco's at arc.
Yeah.
Or just,
or just bad decision making.
It's all,
we're looking at a place today where you guys looking just Hollywood hills on
the other side of,
yeah.
It's just,
it's a nice,
yeah,
but it's a nightmare.
All that stuff.
Can you think of it?
They're like,
oh,
the drainage.
I went to a super rich dude's house.
How much does that one take?
A guess.
$10 million.
A little more.
No Way.
At 2.2 well you don't mind cause it's a DUPLO.
They split it.
It it.
Those are two apartments they rent,
right?
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's to one side is a door or the right and lefts or doors.
Yeah.
So what La does is they take these old buildings,
split them like that,
so then they can make twice the money.
The property is,
the property can't be worth that much.
It's just the fact that they can rent it to two people.
That's a lot of money,
man.
Wow.
Oh my God.
This is 1.5 0.5 how big is it?
1,000.
A thousand square feet.
Square feet.
Stupid one.
That's the size of this studio,
right?
That's the size of where the mics are inside of here.
It's pretty close.
A thousand square feet is really,
I mean if you're one dude living by yourself,
like maybe you've got a dog.
Yeah.
But then that one dude would just rent.
He probably should.
They,
unless he's just real simple.
Like there's those people that buy those miniature houses.
Ever seen those tiny houses,
tiny house that you want to talk about?
Warm whole shit.
I got it.
I got ended that so deep,
Dude.
I was like,
what if I did that?
What if I did a tiny how shit.
Okay.